good afternoon
is Tom hard I'm day
the Graduate School of Arts and Sciences
and i'd like to welcome you all to the
company of scholars lectures from the
graduate school for this year this is
the first of four lectures that were
featuring this year we've got a bit of a
theme you might have to come to all four
lectures to figure out what the theme is
but i'll tell you about jacob hacker our
first speaker in just a moment january
22nd Beverly gauge from the history
department will be speaking on J Edgar
Hoover and his role in the founding of
the conservative movement in the United
States on februari 19th Katherine law
firm from religious studies is going to
be speaking about the role of religion
and parenting in the US she does
fantastically interesting things and
then on April second paul tipton from
the physics department is going to talk
about whether the world's public have
gotten their money's worth in the search
for the Higgs boson which is a big
physics project in in Switzerland he
works on our speaker today is Jacob
hacker Jacob received his undergraduate
degree from Harvard and his PhD from
Yale in the year 2000 he is now
professor of political science a
director event suit for social and
policy studies here at Yale Jacob is a
prolific author of works dealing with
fairness and our democracy and that's
what he's going to be talking about
today I believe he's a public figure who
was prominently featured in many of the
debates about the health care reform and
were really thrilled to have a lead off
our series this year we intended to have
this lecture at the end of October to
sort of energized everybody at the end
of the political campaign but superstorm
sandy intervened so we had to literally
take a raincheck here on the lecture but
perhaps now is even a better time for
Jacob to share his thoughts on is
America
is it American politics undermining the
American dream Jacob thanks Tom well I'm
I'm very pleased to hear to be here and
thank you very much for the kind
introduction whenever you hear
prominently featured you should he said
I was prominently featured in health
care debate you should substitute
viciously attacked but that's okay this
is this is this is why political
scientists who get engaged in policy
debates you need to have thick skin I
want to thank Dean Pollard i want to
thank Rob and luda sir for helping put
this together and I want to mention the
institution for social and Policy
Studies really briefly because this is a
jail institution dedicated to
interdisciplinary work in the social
sciences it's really focused on
precisely encouraging scholars to do
work that's engaged with pressing policy
debates we're doing a lot I became
director of the institution last year we
have a new graduate policy fellows
program if you're a graduate student and
interested in public policy should look
into it we're also doing a lot of events
in fact we're doing one tomorrow jointly
with the law school and the fiscal cliff
for those who are interested I'm going
to spare you what you've probably been
hearing so much about and actually not
talk too much about the fiscal cliff
debate today but i will i will say a
little bit about it so I'm going to keep
my preliminary remarks relatively short
because I want to be able to delve into
some pretty complicated issues in about
45 minutes and whenever I'm under these
kind of time constraints I'm reminded of
an evaluation that I received when I was
a new assistant professor here at Yale
and it began quite promising Lee it said
professor hacker if I had just 15
minutes to live I'd want to spend them
in your class because that way it would
seem like an hour
okay what I do have I do have one last
thanks I want to thank my co-author Paul
Pierson with whom I wrote
winner-take-all politics this is a book
that has now been out for a couple years
after a year of surfing along and the
high three hundred thousands on Amazon
it was featured on Bill Moyers new
program on PBS and and managed to
momentarily break into the top 30 on the
New York Times paperback bestseller list
thus according to our pub my publisher I
am now a new york times bestselling
author forevermore so I'll take what I
can get so I have been waiting to give
this talk for a long time hurricane
sandy of course intervened I'm going to
forego showing you the slide that Karrde
that correctly predicted every electoral
college vote because because it was
copied from nate silver's website okay
so enough jokes I want to get to
something that's unfortunately a lot
darker and I will motivate that focus
with a report really excellent report
that came out from the Pew Research
Center a nonpartisan Public Policy
Center late earlier this year the report
showed what most of you who have been
paying attention to the economy and to
our politics know well that is that this
has been an extremely difficult period
and it's not just the Great Recession if
you look over the last 20 or 30 years
this has been a period in which
middle-class wages and incomes have
grown slowly I'll show some more on that
in a moment while the economic strains
facing families in many cases have
increased most most Americans feel as if
inequality is risen not surprisingly and
most who believe that it has gone up do
not think it's a good thing and you know
you the pollsters are picking up this
and perhaps the most I thought perhaps
the most telling moment in recent debate
over our governmental institution came
when Senator Michael Bennet of Colorado
went to the
floor and presented a slide that looks
something like this this is the US
Congress's approval rating a sandwich
between that of Hugo Chavez and Fidel
Castro I note with some mirth that Paris
Hilton is substantially more popular
than the contemporary Congress but you
don't have to look at these polls to
sense the the era of concern this
election was a nasty and difficult fight
one that perhaps provided an inspiring
end for half the population or slightly
more slightly more but which was but
which came on the heels of a very
difficult period in American politics
one that shows no signs of changing soon
and I think it's worth stepping back
from the debate over tax and budget
policies to look at the sort of larger
longer-term trajectory of the American
dream what I call here the American
Dream which is really by which I mean
really the the basic idea that in the
United States if you work hard if you
play by the rules that you'll be able to
get ahead and that your children will
have a better life than than you had and
this idea this is so closely tied up
with the idea of the middle class the
United States has come under pretty
significant strain and perhaps the most
notable feature of that strain has been
degree to which there seems to have been
a divorce between the income and wealth
of those at the very top and the rest of
Americans it's really striking and I'll
show some figures in a moment just how
concentrated the economic gains the last
20 or 30 years have been the top point
one percent of Americans so the richest
one in a thousand taxpaying households
have seen their real incomes more than
quadruple since the 1970s and it's and
it's been increasingly difficult for
politicians to ignore this this central
change back in 2006 hank paulson and the
Treasury secretary said I think somewhat
defensively growing inequality is simply
an economic reality and it's neither
fair nor useful to blame any political
party
now you know we we might understand why
Paulson was dismissive he was of course
defending the administration he led and
there was no doubt which party he meant
when he said one was being unfairly or
uselessly blamed but in fact paulson's
view that this is simply a massive
economic transformation i think is the
common view among both popular
commentators and scholars who study
inequality at least until recently it's
certainly been the view among those who
have been on the winning end of these
trends back a year earlier before
Paulson statement in 2005 Sandy Weill
said in a New York Times profile this is
the former head of Citigroup he said
people can look at the last 25 years and
say this is an incredibly unique period
of time we didn't rely on somebody else
to build what we built and in this view
the Titans of Finance who are surfing
the waves of this new global economy are
simply superstars who've benefited from
an enlargement of the market shift
towards greater reliance on financial
instruments major changes in our society
they've rewarded talent of the sort that
Sandy Weill possesses so it's worth
knowing that before he was deposed as
head of Citigroup there was a plaque on
the wall of Sandy Wiles office it was
four feet wide apparently wood with a
glass cover and etched in that glass was
a picture of Sandy Weill in his name and
below it it said Sandy Weill Shatterer
of glass-steagall now for those who
don't get the inside reference
glass-steagall was of course the New
Deal regulations who helped whose repeal
help Citigroup form the massive banking
behemoth that in turn helped Isles net
worth skyrocket so politics and
government were intimately involved in
sandy Wiles rise and I'll argue are
intimately involved in the rise of the
very rich over the last generation more
broadly now this isn't a story about one
party or a few
bad apples at the top it's a deeper
story about how our democracy has
changed in a sense it's a puzzle inside
a riddle inside a mystery the puzzle is
why American society has become so much
more unequal over the last generation
and in this specific way that I've
already talked about the concentration
of rewards at the at the very top the
riddle and is how as we show in the book
this wasn't just a passive result of
natural inevitable market forces so
forth market forces played an important
role but also the result of things that
our leaders did and deliberately didn't
do to redistribute income and remake
markets and that leads of course to the
mystery which is how did this happen
right our political system may not do
many things well but one thing it is
supposed to do well and been set up to
do well is to moderate political forces
to ensure that the middle of the
political spectrum and the middle class
has political sway now I'd like to
provide the whole answer to this these
mysteries riddles and puzzles but I'm
not going to be able to i'm going to
give you a sense of some of the clues
that Paul and I discuss in our book and
some of the indictments that we offer
and then I want to spend a little bit of
time talking about where I think this
leaves us in the wake of a tightly
fought election and against a backdrop
of a looming fiscal cliff so the way we
think about inequality I think that we
are ingrained to think about inequality
is about to have not and the haves those
at the bottom who are barely getting by
and the rest of Americans the shift that
I want you to make in your thinking that
will really help you understand what's
happened is to think instead about to
have it all at the top and the rest of
Americans we've transformed in the last
generation into a society in which
economic rewards are much much more
concentrated at the top now I'm going to
show you some statistics that really
drive this home they're not from my own
work they're from interpretations of
congressional budget office and IRS data
but but I think they really make things
I want to warn you since I am going to
show these charts that that I have a
fondness for statistics i guess probably
with this audience that's not as big of
a problem as it as it is with some
others but my defense here came from
Moyers himself who once said that it is
the mark of an educated man to be deeply
moved by statistics so so I hope you
share my passion okay I'm not the only
one who feels this way remember Occupy
Wall Street this rather short lived but
nonetheless explosive political protest
featured signs like this one here since
when have we had a political protest
that use Congressional Budget Office
data to make its point and you can
already see here what I'm going to show
you in a moment this remarkable rise in
the incomes of the top 1% and if you're
just glancing at this you'll notice
right away that this rise with the
exception of these spikes and declines
which reflect mostly the stock market is
very continue its very relatively stable
over the last generation that is it's
been a feature of our politics now for
about 30 years let me show you this a
little bit more clearly so here I'm
taking the CBO's data and going back to
nineteen seventy-nine the first year
available and this is just on the left
the real incomes of these different
income groups so we have the lowest
through the top the fourth fifth so
that's the 60th to 80th percentile 20th
bottom twenty percent the 60s to 80s and
then I've simply broken the top 1% out
of the 80th to 90th percentiles since
we've been talking about the bottom
ninety nine percent in the top 1% a lot
this is not very strange but I should
say that the time I was doing this that
this was actually not as commonly done
in a lot of the research and i'll show
you that it matters quite a bit so let's
go back to nineteen seventy-nine we're
looking at real dollars these include
all public and private benefits as best
they can measure them and federal taxes
though not state and local taxes just so
you know state and local taxes have
increased a lot over the last generation
much more than federal taxes and they're
more regressive so if any
this would understate the changes that
have taken place so you can see if you
go back to nineteen seventy-nine the top
1% had an average income of you know in
the four hundred thousand dollars a year
range and that was much greater than the
the middle fifth over here which had an
average income that was more in the 40
45 thousand dollar range but let's
fast-forward to 2007 again real dollars
if a picture is worth a thousand words
or in this case I guess 1.4 million
words this one is it right so what you
can see here is really all groups have
seen some gains the gains have been most
dramatic at the very top and I'll say in
a moment that this in some ways over
sunder states to transformation since
for the middle and blend these lower
groups a lot of these gains have been to
do not to rising wages but to increased
family work hours that's not as true at
the very top so the top 1% has seen its
scene about more than a third of all
income gains over this period and and
really it's even more dramatic if you
look at the 2000s when over half of all
income gains went to the top 1% but in
some ways this is actually it's hard to
believe an understatement of how
concentrated the games are done what if
we just took this top 1% this group
rarefied group that we talked about so
much and broke it into its various
constituent parts so we can go here from
the bottom half of the top 1% all the
way up to the top wait Oh 1% this is
nosebleed territory in the income
distribution I think the technical term
for this group is the ordinary rich and
the technical term for this group will
say the stinking rich okay so the top
point 0 1 percent to the bottom half of
the top 1% again 1979 you can see there
is inequality among the top 1% but
what's really striking is again how
concentrated the gains are within the
top 1% so one wonders if the slogan of
Occupy Wall Street might have been or at
least maybe if the vice pres
start watch what marching on Washington
we are the ninety-nine point nine
percent you know we got a little bit of
a taste of this during the presidential
campaign and funnily enough it was
during the Republican primary
liberal massachusetts governor is going
to come to be able to go and go and
relate to wait to folks as well as the
guy beside someone coal miner but he
says bicha $10,000 holding back that's
just a lot of money for most people i
guess around they would like to go back
all the money he's earned for
bankrupting companies and laying off the
boys over his years of thing that i
would be glad then listen
struck by the political analysis that
the sheer volume meant a game which has
run by round his back she's packed by
his money that I was an ads same things
that are fast that's somehow washington
plays the game isn't that exactly what's
sick about this country right now is
that what the American people are tired
of is using my influence rigging the
system in some way to be believing at
the bottom of believing in free people
of free markets go back those
regulations that are strangling the
American entrepreneurship for more tax
rates considerably not job creators
getting it out of the way over text much
regulation and praising the people great
jobs oh right
okay so this this debate during the
Republican primaries I think really
drove home the extent to which there was
even debate about the very very top
pulling away from the rest of the rich
within the top 1% now I was just going
to mention a couple quick things I noted
already that much of the gain in income
for the middle came from increased
family work hours you can see here that
over the last 30 years or so that really
the gains in productivity which were
relatively substantial though slower
than they had been in the in the
previous generation were not matched by
gains and compensation now there's some
issues with the compensation data but
this does include benefits you can see
that it's male workers in particular the
white line here so I really no no gains
now and this is true actually
surprisingly high up the educational
spectrum so for example if you look at
entry-level male workers with a college
degree their income gains over the last
30 years have been relatively modest
they're less likely for for example to
have health insurance at their place of
work so these strains have been have
been actually felt by many Americans who
are actually relatively well educated
and moreover and I think this is the
important point it's hard to reconcile
those really sharp gains at the top with
a model that it's focused just on sort
of generalized return to education right
where you would expect that the games
would be much more broadly diffused so
in general then when people start to
look at what's happening at the top and
I'm going to skip over a couple things
that I think are of interest but I don't
want to take up too much time in general
when you look at what's happening at the
very top you start to question the sort
of the story that is emphasizing skill
what what is often called skilled bias
technological change by economist
but that's a that's a kind of negative
explanation or negative negative account
in the sense that the skill bias
technological change arguments don't
seem to be wholly consistent with how
concentrated the games have gains have
been I want to provide a moment a much
more positive account that sort of it
attempts to attribute many of these
changes to changes in public policy the
last clue in this is that the United
States is not unique but quite
distinctive in the concentration of
income at the very top so you may be
aware that the economist emmanuel saez
and his colleagues have put together the
best available data across national data
on the concentration of income at the
top based on tax statistics and what
they've done is put these together in
the sink in this source called the world
top incomes database and if you take
that data and you look back in the early
1970s you can see a remarkable
similarity across rich countries in the
share of income going to the top 1% I
should note that these numbers do not
include capital gains which are very
hard to compare across countries that's
a significant oversight as well as I'll
show in a moment capital gains are very
concentrated at the top and they're much
more prevalent in the United States than
in many other rich countries so again if
anything these numbers understate the
difference between the United States and
at least the non angle of countries you
can see here if we go to the the last
year available in the top incomes
database which is not always the same
but it doesn't change the conclusion
much you can see here that the United
States looks more like the so-called
Anglo countries Australia Canada New
Zealand UK and yet even among those
countries the gains at the very top have
been much more market this number
including capital gains in two thousand
seven or so was around twenty-five
percent which was the highest point
reached since on the eve of the Great
Depression you can see though that a
number of countries have seen small
increases some have seen almost none at
all the United States really stands out
raising the question again of why if
there's broad technological forces at
work across these countries at
and that are increasing the returns of
Education the gains have been so much
more concentrated the United States than
in other rich countries now the first
answer to this question is if we these
are most of the figures i've shown you
are in pre-tax pre-tax data as with this
but i did show you that figure before
the Congressional Budget Office figure
that showed post tax data and so
obviously the first question you might
want to ask is well has government
played a role in in tamping down the
inequalities that are occurring in
pre-tax data and the Congressional
Budget Office is answered this question
pretty definitively in a recent report
and you can see here that United States
over the period of rising inequality has
actually done less to reduce the
so-called Gini index through tax federal
taxes and transfers whereas the Gini
index reduced inequality by almost a
quarter sorry whereas taxes and
transfers reduce the Gini index by
almost a quarter in nineteen eight
nineteen seventy-nine the number was
closer to seventeen percent in 2007 with
most of the change occurring because of
the less redistributed quality of
transfers over that period but this is
this suggests that United States and and
if you look in comparative relief its
distinctive that the United States did
less to reduce inequality but it doesn't
really answer the question of what
happened at the very top according to
the Congressional Budget Office about
half of the rise in the Gini index in
the United States is due to income gains
at the top that is the pulling away of
the top 1% an increasing dispersion of
income within that and if we're going to
try to understand the role of government
in changing inequality in the United
States we're obviously going to have to
look beyond just a taxes and public
transfers or at least the broad effect
of taxes and public transfers so the
first thing to say is that if we're
looking at the top we really need to ask
what were the policies that affected the
top the most and the most obvious is tax
policy so if you go back to the 1960s
here and this is from data that comes
from saez and Poquette Poquette e
you can see that income tax rates have
come down very sharply at the very top
and most of that get that change by the
way happens well before the Bush tax
cuts of 2001 for the broad just middle
of the distribution you can see there
has really been no change in the average
effective federal tax rate so this this
is a remarkable change and it is worth
quite a bit to those at the very top in
just between the the Clinton tax rates
of the 1990s and 2007 the average
effective income tax rate paid by the
top 400 taxpayers which is a common
metric the IRS puts out decline from
around thirty percent to sixteen point
five percent so when we hear talk about
paying say only a fortunate romney
paying only a fourteen percent effective
tax rate it's actually not that uncommon
among the very richest taxpayers to pay
something on that scale so for the top
400 taxpayers their average income tax
rate went down from thirty percent to
sixteen point five percent over this
period that was worth about forty six
million dollars for every taxpayer in
that top four hundred group so each
taxpayer received essentially a 406
million dollars because of the decline
in tax rates just since the mid-1990s
and there was just a new report out from
the IRS showing that these tax rates
have continued to fall particularly as
more and more of the income of those at
the top is is received in the form of
capital gains which is taxed at only
fifteen percent currently so according
to new IRS data the average income tax
rate for households with income above
ten million dollars that's about the
point top point one percent fell from
twenty two point four percent effective
income tax rate to about a twenty
percent effective income tax rate in
2010 nonetheless much of the change that
we're talking about is before government
taxes and benefits and there's a
tendency in the research to assume that
that portion of the change in income
must be a political must have occurred
without the influence of government but
if you think about it for just a
that's obviously a very blinkered view
of the role of government after all
governments not only tax-and-spend they
also regulate and shape the market in
profound ways and those way and those
ways that they do that can have an
enormous effect on the distribution of
income in the market even before
governments visible hand reaches in to
tax or spend I made this point in Paul
and I made in the in the book and I
wrote a paper that I presented in
Britain and the the young aspiring
Labour Party leader Miliband ed Miliband
was at the at the conference and was
taken by it and started talking about it
on the campaign trail and it so happened
that not within a relatively short
period of time I found myself the
subject of question time in here we are
did it die mr. speaker this stage in the
Proceedings I say to the party opposite
hasn't got any plans but on this
occasion I can reach all the house they
have got so bad they got a new plan it's
called pre distribution means is that
you spend the money before you actually
get it
i'll text women's about is an economy is
that a call me that doesn't have work
for a few of the top the work
is not about a prime minister who cuts
taxes for millionaires while raising
taxes for everyone
he gets up to reply he can answer the
question which he so far hasn't answered
is he gonna be a beneficiary of the 50p
tax cut this is generated
I never too I know you just want to talk
about Cree distribution work Mr Speaker
I can tell him about his new guru his
new guru is called I'm not making this
up the man who invented free
distribution he's cool he's gone our
minds up mister they don't hear border
house before the Amazon both sides need
to calm down let's hear the premises
awesome surprise from the new guru he's
called mr. Jay hacker this
recommendation is that we spend an extra
200 billion and borrow an extra 200
billion in this Parliament face
recognition but in the work I've done
I've discovered his new book it is
published by princeton university press
and it's called the road to nowhere he's
there already
okay yes so another agate you know deep
engagement I received in the public
sphere so the the idea of pre
distribution is not have nothing to do
with either the labor or conservative
parties platforms but the idea is
basically that there are a lot of ways
in which government can shape the
distribution of market income and in the
book we talked about several areas from
corporate governance to financial
regulation to industrial relations I
think the best example is indeed
financial regulation and if we remember
the story of Sandy Weill will remember
that deregulation was a huge part of the
lead-up to the financial crisis and the
huge gains that happened at the top
there's still a large amount of debate
about the exact role of a financial
deregulation in the financial crisis but
there's been a number of important
pieces of work on this including this
paper by Thomas Philip on and Philip
reshef I'm looking at the relationship
between financial deregulation and
relative wages in the financial industry
now the there are two things to note
here one is that if you see here this
relative wage which is the sort of
orangish red line here that the that it
tracks almost perfectly the the u-shaped
trajectory of the top one percent over
the course of the 20th century that is
there was a large decline in the
relative wage and Finance after the New
Deal regulations and the stock market
crash and then over the last 20 years or
so 30 years or so with hand in hand with
financial regulation there's been an
increase in the relative wage in finance
what the relative wages is basically
what simile educated and skilled workers
earn in finance relative to workers in
other fields and this is just another
way of saying that for a long time
people in finance didn't earn a lot of
money in the last generation they have
now this is a purely correlational
relation relationship here but you can
see here they also construct an index of
financial deregulation which track
the the rise in the financial wage
premium quite closely another another
thing that seems to track what happened
in Bitra deregulation is financial
instability if you look here and this is
from David Moss of the Harvard Business
School there's a lot more going on this
is the share of income going to the top
10% it's very similar to in terms of its
trajectory to the share of income going
to the top 1% or that wage premium I
just showed you and then these blue and
these red lines are just various
measures of financial instability total
bank failures or the total deposits have
failed in assisted institutions as a
share of GDP and that's reveal it's
revealing that the New Deal reforms seem
to put an end to the repeated endemic
financial crises that it occurred prior
to the Great Depression and it's only in
the last 30 years in line with
deregulation that we've seen more
financial instability culminating in the
financial crisis of 2008 and nine you'll
see here that because of the increasing
consolidation of the financial sector
that actually bank failures are not
actually very high this is a savings and
loan crisis we're far more banks failed
but the deposits of course under under
the assets under of failed institutions
of course are enormous and the the
financial story is a huge part of the
story of what happened to the top point
one percent in fact if you look at the
tax records of this rarified group
you'll find that about six and ten or
corporate or financial executives about
two and ten our financial executives
about six and ten four and ten or
corporate executives so corporate
governance is another part of the story
that we tell in each of these areas the
changes were tied up very much with the
increasing role of Finance which in turn
was a parsley a reflection of shifts in
public policy bipartisan shifts i should
add that i'll talk about in just a
moment now part of this was about
changing policy and so you saw major
regulatory changes over this period but
in fact a lot of it was simply about
failing to update policy in the face of
changing market structures and that's
another way in which public policy and
politics can play an important role in
shaping the distribution that we don't
pay much attention to in the book we
call this drift and drift is simply when
when the world changes but policy
doesn't in ways that are intended by key
actors and drift is most notable and
most and most political in many ways
when it involves the blocking activity
of very powerful private actors and this
was certainly the story in finance
there's a great moment or great moment
for us in the debate over accounting law
changes when the head of the SEC went to
the then chair of the Banking Committee
phil gramm and asked for some updates of
policy graham looked at him and I'm not
going to try to do the Texas accent and
said unless the waters are crimson with
the blood of investors I don't want you
engaging in any regulatory flights of
fancy so here was a clear case in which
a very powerful private actor situated
private political actor was standing in
the way of regulatory updating we see
this again and again over this period
because the the industry interest were
so much more energized and organized
around these issues look at Sandy while
putting so much more money into politics
than they ever had and we're so much
more capable of taking advantage of the
increasing and capacity of American
political institutions to act on a lot
of issues and that's that's I'm going to
move now to talking about some of the
larger political changes that took place
so of my 33 opening questions what was
the what was the nature of the change
what were some of the policies that
played a role and why did government do
it what what were the political what's
the political story behind it I want to
turn to this last question before
offering some broader reflections so if
the if the winner-take-all economy if
this rise was made substantially in
Washington that really raises a
fundamental puzzle it's it's again easy
to see why government will often cater
to large majorities that are intense in
their preferences but it's harder to
to think about why would you get
policies over a long period of time that
were that had such a concentrated set of
beneficiaries how could this happen in a
democracy that's so often seen is so
responsive to middle-class concerns you
know we can see some politic some and I
think one of the aspects of it that I
think we have to understand is that it's
been harder and harder as i was just
hinting for our political institutions
to act at all and perhaps the most
important reason for that is the rise of
the senate filibuster now for all of
those who've seen mr. Smith goes to
Washington we have this image in her
mind of the filibuster as this great
story to institution where senators go
to the floor and debate for hours on end
at the time that this movie was made the
filibuster was actually extremely rare
and it did take this form it was not
used usually by by people seeking such
lofty ends as mr. Smith was but by
southern racist seeking to prevent civil
rights legislation but nonetheless it
was rarely used and it was used
typically by intense minorities that
were willing to pay the price of going
to the floor and debating for long long
periods of time that has changed
dramatically the filibuster and this is
cloture filings to end Senate
filibusters as you can see was
relatively rare up until this period of
that we've seen this last generation and
you can see that it's even concentrated
within that period really over the last
few years so uh since the if you look at
the 40 years before nineteen seventy
there were fewer than 40 cloture filings
across that entire period in the 40
years after there's been more than 800
cloture filings and just the two the
four years leading up to 2010 there were
more than 200 cloture filings alone and
that's shown no sign of declining in the
last two years I should note it if you
had any question James Madison you know
we tend to think of this as a
constitutional and aspect of our
constitutional government but the
filibuster is really an aspect of Senate
rules that has no mention in the
Constitution and in fact really runs
against the grain
many of the majoritarian sentiments of
the founders here's James Madison saying
that with the exception of a few areas
designed to sort of create separate
institutions sharing powers like the
veto having the majority be overruled by
the minority violated the fundamental
principle of free government and the
root the result of this rise in the use
of the filibuster both reflects and has
embedded rising partisan polarization
within Congress about which I'm sure
you've heard a lot I'll show you just
one result of that this is a number of
laws passed per session of Congress and
you can see that that this last Congress
really stands out in fact I think it's
the least productive Congress since the
middle of the late of the last of the
19th century just by way of comparison
that's the do-nothing Congress that
Harry Truman talk to that it passed 903
laws as compared with about 170 in the
last Congress so in action is an
important important part of the story
the sorry
the other aspect of the story about
which we've heard a lot lately is the
transformation of the organized interest
environment around government and so
it's not just that it's harder for
political leaders to act but also that
they're facing much greater organized
pressure on many policy issues than they
were a generation ago the story we tell
in our book is really of the sort of
massive counter mobilization of
organized corporate interest in the
1970s around issues of regulation there
was a real backlash in the corporate
community against Ralph Nader and
against some of the really huge
regulatory changes that were pursued
under Richard Nixon such as the EPA and
that led into a major mobilization
around both lobbying and campaigns and I
mentioned lobbying first because
lobbying is where corporations really
put their money the typical company
spends about 10 to 10 times that spends
money on politics spends about 10 times
as much on lobbying as they do on
campaigns and they're spending a lot
more than they were a generation ago
they're also spending a lot more on
campaigns we've seen that in the last
election but sometimes it's forgotten
just how dramatic the shift has been in
real dollars it's remarkable how little
was being spent on elections 20 or 30
years ago now in this last in this last
election and I think in 2008 you could
argue that a lot of the money was used
for ends that we might support like
mobilizing voters the point is though
that the the role of money has
dramatically increased over this period
and the need to get it through various
means is much greater for politicians
than it has ever been and in both those
respects I think we there's an
asymmetric effect on the two major
political parties and that's I think a
hugely important aspect of the political
debates today and of the debates that
was that that have and the policy
changes that led to to these shifts that
I've been talking about for the
Republican Party this dramatic
transformation has been the rise of
money
the rise of lobbying the mobilization of
the corporate community has been
emboldened right it is pushed
Republicans to identify more strongly
with many of their core principles and
policy goals most notably tax cuts for
the for Democrats the changes have been
much less clear and much more cross
pressuring because for Democrats they
have seen simultaneously the rise in
corporate lobbying and of contributions
coming from the business sector but also
have been torn between that and their
their dwindling labor base which is lost
enormous ground over this period and so
you see this I think in a lot of things
but perhaps most notably you see it in
the remarkable asymmetry in the
polarization of the two parties now
whenever we talk about polarization I
think we assume that it's symmetrical
because after all in political science
the assumption is that the two parties
are competing for the middle and that
the party that deviates farthest from
the center absent a shift and where the
middle is is going to lose elections but
in fact the most clear implication of
much of the research has been done by
political scientist is it polarization
has actually been quite dramatically a
cement symmetrical with Republicans
moving farther to the right than
Democrats have moved to the left now I
think thats related to the remarkable
shifts in the organizational universe
that I've been talking about the decline
of middle-class organizations like labor
unions and cross class civic
organizations the rise of lobbying and
corporate organization but I think it's
also notable that it's probably driven
also by the much different kinds of
activists bases within the two parties
and the better effectiveness of the
Republican Party it if you look at say
Grover Norquist or America or the club
for growth at using sort of recruitment
and certification processing and
auditing processes to try to discipline
Republican members of Congress
particularly through primaries whatever
the exact balance of explanations we
really see it in the numbers and these
numbers come from a remarkable effort by
two political scientists
pool and Howard Rosenthal to chart the
ideological landscape of American
politics based on members votes now I'm
going to use these numbers in it and a
somewhat I don't know if unorthodox is
the right way but to keep with that
metaphor it's perhaps not the most
kosher way to use these I'm going to
start with the levels of the average
levels in the 1970s for the for the two
parties and then look at how the parties
have evolved over the last 35 years or
so the reason why this is not entirely
kosher is that there is no natural base
for these numbers it turns out that over
the whole congressional history that the
mean is zero and also they're hard to
compare over very long spans of time
although they try to anchor them with
members who are overlapping in time so
let me show you the numbers and you'll
you'll see that it really doesn't matter
because they could be off by a very
large order of magnitude and the story
would be the same okay so if you look at
house democrats they become about
twenty-two percent more liberal again
all the caveats House Senate Democrats
have become a little bit more liberal on
these DW nominate scores on the economic
dimension of American politics which is
the main dimension according to pool and
Rosenthal Senate Republicans on the
other hand have become about
seventy-three percent more conservative
according to this and it will not
surprise you to see a massive increase
in the conservative House Republicans if
you take these DW nominate scores and
map them on to congressional history you
get a figure that looks like this this
may be the single coolest figure that I
found in American politics it's also
completely unintelligible unless I
explain it but let me just tell you that
these different shades of red and blue
indicate how conservative the members
are this shows you entrances of new
cohorts so here you get a class of
moderate sort of middle of the middle of
the Republican Road Republicans in
recent years you can see more and more
of the Republicans who come in have been
on the right side of the spectrum this
for example is Paul Ryan here who's a
very conservative Republican and you can
see the story is not the same on the
Democratic side that is to say there has
been much more
there have been many more centrist and
and sort of moderate left democrats and
there have been centrist and moderate
right Republicans you can actually get
this figurin if you're interested I'll
provide the link that goes all the way
back to the founding of Congress a few
of us have any sense of what the
relative influx of wigs and federalist
means today but for recent American
politics this picture tells us a lot it
tells us first of all these parties have
been remarkably well balanced and that
the Republican Party is seen since the
mid-1990s 1994 to be exact a very large
influx of very conservative Republicans
the political science sean therriault
has calculated that almost all of the
polarization of American politics this
is remarkable is due to what he calls
the Gingrich senators that is and the
in-house and House King Grich that get
sorry all the polarization the Senate is
due to what he calls the Gingrich
senators which is actually conservative
House Republicans who've moved over to
the Senate side this is one reason and
then I promise I will wrap up and this
is one reason why those who say
gerrymandering couldn't play any role in
this story might be wrong because if the
house if the house is seating the very
conservative Republicans over to the
Senate or liberal democrats that's one
of the ways in which gerrymandering or
other house centered explanations of
increased polarization might spill over
onto the Senate so the this polarization
raises a question of whether you see
something comparable in public opinion
and I'll just say that there is very
little sign of overall polarization of
the public that is desperate measures of
dispersion do not show a big increase in
polarization on social issues both sides
of the political spectrum have actually
moved substantially to the left over the
last generation on economic issues it's
a much more stable picture but we do see
and this is what I mentioned before
there is a conservative activist base
that's more intense than you see on the
Republican on the Democratic side of the
aisle and that may be an important part
of the story but I think it's an
important part of the story that
actually brings us back
to the to the fundamental issue that I
raised before what we've seen over the
last generation is is a shift in policy
that has actually been in quite
inegalitarian right inequality has gone
up in the market in part because of
policy changes I've discussed and in
addition market changes in inequality
have not been matched by policy shifts
that have pushed back against that
rising inequality a lot of that has been
driven by an action rather than action
and a lot of that inaction is driven by
polarization and the rising increase and
the use of the filibuster and the reason
that I believe that this partisan story
is linked in many ways is that if you
start to look at public views about
inequality about public policy what you
find is a much more complex view than
you get from the kind of popular
accounts of of welfare state supporting
Democrats on the one hand and highly
conservative Republicans on the other
there's a there was a famous article in
the 19th in the in the 1960s that argued
that America's were operational kansara
philosophical conservatives and
operational liberals that is they were
philosophically worried about government
but loved everything that government did
and in fact you find even among tea
party supporters very strong support for
many core public programs at the same
time even among Democrats you find
concern that we're not addressing st.
some of the festering fiscal problems of
our country the point is that in many
ways I think the story of the last
generation is of politics has been
pulled away from middle class and and
driven it increasingly by elite
activists the role of money in American
politics and perhaps most pervasive the
increasing and capacity of our political
system to act at all now this may sound
like an extremely depressing story but I
don't see it as that I think that if the
depressing story in many ways is the one
that we so often hear that this is only
about globalization and technological
change that our government really can do
very little to deal with it if
politics is a very important part of the
increasing strains facing middle-class
Americans then politics can be part of
the solution as well I do not I do not
want to pretend that that addressing
these problems would be easy we're not
going to revamp our Constitution but I
think we could at least have a few clear
priorities that are drawn out of some of
the analysis that I've offered today
first we should be doing what we can to
reduce or resist barriers to policy
updating and I think filibuster reform
is an important part of that task second
we should be trying insofar as possible
to reduce the ability to translate money
into power the essence of American
democracy is as the two Roosevelts
famously said at different points in
time is the ideal of political equality
and that rests on having some some kinds
of flood walls between the market and
democracy inequality in our society is
one thing having that inequality
translate into political inequality is
quite another and fine finally I think
and there's maybe a hopeful sign in this
last election that we should be striving
not necessarily for a more parliamentary
system even though that's what our
political structure has increasingly
become with unified parties fighting it
out but for a more majoritarian system
one in which the majority preferences on
things like higher tax cuts tax rates on
the very well-off should be able to
whenever possible and not inconsistent
with other critical rights dominate and
when you look at the polls what you find
is that for most Americans they do not
feel that the middle class has that kind
of influence a poll that was done at the
during the height of the fight over
health care and financial reform a time
when the government was really grappling
with issues of critical concern to
middle-class Americans I think drives
home the sense of cynicism that many
Americans feel you can see here that
when asked whether government economic
policies had helped large banks and
financial institutions a great deal
fifty-three percent
of Americans agreed with that but when
asked if they were helping middle-class
people or small businesses only about
two percent of Americans who agreed a
great deal so there's a sense among many
Americans the system is not working well
to represent the middle class and I
think that some of the reforms that i'm
talking about might address that concern
so thank you